[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and joining me
today is a professor of economics at
George Mason University an author an
anarcho-capitalist and a pacifist
Brian Kaplan welcome to the Reuben
report thanks a lot for having me a lot
of good buzzwords in there and we're
going to get to all of them but first
what's it like being a professor on a
campus these days that doesn't identify
as a progressive is that tough are you
getting rocks thrown at you every day
how's that going my life is perfectly
fine nothing's ever had nothing bad has
ever happened to me I don't even know
I've ever gotten a negative comment on a
student evaluation to be fair I'm in the
economics department at George Mason
University which is a very unusual place
there's a lot of libertarian and free
market oriented people there but also
you what I say is that the stories you
hear on the video while generally true
if you remember how many people are on
campus how many professors there are so
if every week you see some horrible
thing happens to one professor that
still leaves you 99.999% of all
professors who had a perfectly fine week
and so far so good for me yeah and you
make a point of saying you're in the
Economics Department yeah probably
insulated from some of this ago because
you have to work with facts and figures
and numbers these are sort of outside of
the realm of where social justice can
hit right right and also just in
economics there's a long history of a
field where you can say really
controversial and shocking things and
people are curious and want to talk
about it in a civilized way rather than
get really mad at you so really only
those I'd say at least half of the
controversial ideas in academia have
come out of economics and the economists
get Nobel prizes for these ideas it's
you know Gary Becker Ramone Friedman
it's not like people are waiting around
for you to say the wrong thing and jump
on you so I mean I do to me is any of
the real differences there's just people
who are very dull there are economists
are very boring but it's not like
they're angry at people for doing other
stuff they're just not doing really
exciting work but there's plenty of room
in economics for people to say almost
anything really and not only get away
with it this is to succeed
you know I mean I've long been telling
people like if you really want to be a
professor try to figure out how to
repackage what you're what you want to
do with economics and then get a PV at
your PC economics you late more money
you'll get tenure you'll get any Oh get
a job easily and you'll be in a very
supportive atmosphere where you can save
you want yeah I can tell you truly
believe in the free market because
you're welcoming people to take your job
right now that's that's pretty good
ideal tenure so I'm not that worried
that way but um and also remember that
the more people in order in order to
become a racer you first have to become
one of my customers and go to grad
school so Metro is not as Unseld finding
my team yeah do you find that professors
of economics either George Mason or I
you were just mentioning a debate you're
doing in a couple days but generally
professors of economics from whatever
you know whatever pathology they believe
in are able to debate and it doesn't get
personal and it can really stick on the
issues and that kind of thing so I
generally say yes again the main problem
is just people who are not interested in
bigger ideas and only want to focus on
their research topics people like that
are not touchy they're not hostile
they're just apathetic or they sometimes
love the idea of you know what you are
doing is not science sometimes I don't
really care about that and you don't
belong here but it's not that they
disagree that you're saying as they
disagree with people taking on bigger
questions of any kind you know that and
you know that's sort of what I've dealt
with in million in my time in academia
is just I want to do big exciting ideas
and a lot of economists frown on that
not because they disagree with the
content but because they disagree with
anything big and exciting yeah so before
we get into some of your big and
exciting ideas do you find that
generally outside of the universities
that just the American populace really
doesn't understand anything about
economics because this is what I see all
the time you know I I can only garner so
much information from social media but I
see people saying things about trade all
the time and immigration all the time
and all these things that are tied back
into economics and I'm like you don't
really seem to know much about anything
yeah so I whole book on this called the
myth of the rational voter biography
shoots bad policies in the book I just
go over all the evidence
on what does the public actually believe
about economics compared to what anyone
who can explain the textbook Thanks and
yeah it's terrible yeah you need a cell
you know what you think about it is so
mean right now here in LA I grew up here
so I will say that until I was 17 I
never heard any arguments against the
minimum wage I never heard any argument
against regulation Pharmaceuticals I
don't think I ever heard any argument
against the welfare state ever again I
was not growing up in Berkeley or some
with some left-wing Haven just growing
up in a normal boring middle-class
suburb here Los Angeles but the kinds of
arguments that economists make and are
aware of are just not even on people's
radar yeah so that's an important to
feature you said there that you didn't
grow up in Berkeley you grew up in a
suburb of Los Angeles but somewhat
blue-collar it was yeah it was really a
middle middle middle class middle class
yeah it was it was it was probably you
know can easily been half Republican in
those days yeah and still like I never
heard any of the very basic economic
arguments critiquing standard popular
regulations you know even so it's like
mm only like you talk to my parents
about rent control and yet they didn't
understand anything about the economists
critique rent control how it causes it
how it causes a shortage housing for
them is like well we own rental property
so we're against it sort of all that be
all they can come up with right so you
know so anything anything but this this
is your very very standard for them not
just the American public but the global
but the global public and throughout
history is just like the very basic
ideas of economics that are in every
textbook are you not known and when
they're heard this is this reckoning so
it's one thing to never heard them but
northern oral reaction is just anger
yeah so table-like because they're so
insulated from any other idea basically
right and also it's just like it just
like why are you saying this boy I can't
we have the minimum wage it's a program
to go and help poor people and then an
economist comes along and says there's a
downside this could cause unemployment
and people's reaction is how could you
say something like that so terrible
yeah the only what Kyle you like you
hate you hate poor people and again this
seems like a parody but I have
experienced this firsthand plenty
yeah what do you do what do you do with
that when when you try to lay out
something and you say well here's data
to support it but it's so emotional to
somebody else
something like minimum wage working
usually I try to connect it to percent
experience because anytime I talk about
talk about the data then someone say
once your data I wanna there must be
plenty of other people of other data so
try to say well look when you fill out a
job application you get to the line on
salary requirements you put a million
dollars an hour
no why not well because I think if I put
too much money then I'm less likely to
get the job
AHA so it's not just me that believes
that if wages are too high that
unemployment result you believe it too
yeah it's just that you don't want to
connect what you know from your own
experience to the world of policy
because it doesn't sound good
yeah I think it's interesting what you
said about your parents they had a
rental property so they didn't like rent
control because obviously you don't want
it if you're the owner of the property
and how we all apply our own life might
be separate from what ours are
philosophical principles are yeah
because I lived in New York City for
about 12 years in an apartment that was
rent stabilized so it was slightly
different than right I controlled but
they could only increase my rent I think
something like you know change every few
years but about 2% a year which for me
as the tenant it was great and they you
know over the course of 12 years my rent
land I think started 16:54 a two-bedroom
apartment on the Upper West and I think
it maxed out at about 2000 so as the
tenant on my side that's pretty great
make the argument I am wrong about that
yes so in terms of your own
self-interest you know you might might
be perfectly right yeah we they're I
mean I would say well there are some
downsides things like quality tends to
go down with rent control so you like to
heat it a heating breaks down and you
can never like I'm going to come across
things so so there is that so you know
this is just you know very standard
result with any kind of price controls
if you can't adjust on the price then
you can adjust on all these other and
all these other ways to adjust on
quality but you're you going to try
charging people for extras things like
that yeah I mean so like you know
there's always going to be people who do
benefit for the policies and if you
happen to be that person then it's very
elegant like you might suppose harder
than I did
you know the the saving grace is that in
general people are not comfortable
arguing for political policy or policies
on self-image to the grounds so you know
you're say look this is very bad for
society people normally want to dispute
that that is bad for ID they don't want
to say well sure it's bad for society
but I'm one of them in the minority
people's benefit list so I like it and
we should have it yeah you know it's
interesting I think the point that you
make there about well they're gonna have
to cut in other ways if they can't raise
your rent so for example am i building
in the winter every winter there would
literally be if we were in the middle of
a storm there would be three or four
days ago where we would not have heat an
old steam heat yes you know four-story
building and there was a couple days
when I was single back then that I
literally was under the covers and my
dog because I didn't want her to play
either and I went to the to the
management building which is a couple
blocks away and I was basically reaming
them out and I remember the woman was
sitting behind bulletproof glass and I
thought this is what's wrong with this
system this woman that she working for a
big company they owned five hundred
buildings were stuck with her I never
fully connected that to rent control or
any we're not inclined to move out to a
full plate price place that had good
heat yeah so that does show how we will
sort of negotiate these strange thing so
let's talk about anarcho-capitalist all
right because I haven't done much on it
I think I've had one in our Co capital T
my friend that guy T on on YouTube who
you should check out if you don't know
great guy in Atlanta
what is anarcho-capitalism so internal
capitalism is the idea that the
so-called minimal functions of the state
are actually more than you really need
and it's about it is not only imaginable
but you know it could but it really
could work to privatize the last
lingering functions of government like
police courts and the law itself again
this is I need the times really crazy so
the way that I usually explain it is
well right now people may say well
government clearly estimate monopoly
over police monopoly over courts
monopoly over law they say government
isn't monopoly over these things right
now right now there's actually more
private security guards in police so but
is that it really that's true so there
you know there are more there are more
people hired by business and communities
to go and do policing than there are
police in like in the official sense
and then you'll see no circuit courts
there is a huge area of private
adjudication there's arbitration there's
any time you probably their credit card
used to the companies involved no you
call the credit card company and they
have their own internal adjudication
system for handling things like this
Facebook if you have problems on
facebook you go into Facebook no you
just you go and you complain with them
and they do something about it and then
you're not sure they really do something
about it in the case of Facebook but
very well similarly minimum they give
you a bunch of options solve your own
problems you can block someone you can
unfriend them you can make sure they
never contact you again so you know they
give you a bunch of remedies that you
have which oh you'll Dave worked out
exactly what it is they want to do about
it and then feel similarly for for
looking a law itself there are many
private organizations that have their
own rules that they apply so again
mentioning obviously oh so private
arbitration you know one of the main
reasons people use private arbitration
is that they don't use regular laws they
use their own laws which are designed to
work better than the government's laws
so you can get your issue resolved in a
few days instead of weeks or years so
you know like usually with pro with
private arbitration they have the
arbitrator actually be someone who knows
what he's doing right so they have
someone who is in fact an expert on this
area business rather than giving it to a
generalist and twelve people who were
too dumb to get out of jury duty yeah so
just just sort of beginning realizing
wow so there's a lot of private more
private alternatives that already exists
right now you know to you know to
government providing these services that
at first glance a lot of people just
have the reaction of it with Justice
Society which is burn in flames if there
were private police or private Korell
private courts or private law look
around it's not burning now there's
already a very large role for the
private sector yeah so and then what I
think you know but I think about
entrecôte capitalism I always just say
right we'll start what we got you
realize that that is not going to lead
anything bad and there's very good
reasons why people are using these
private alternatives right now which is
they're better they're worth the money
you get you you actually go you get
better quality for for of you know not
only for a lower price but remember
these are private companies competing
with free government services and
they're still carving out a big
architecture themselves because so many
people are so dissatisfied with
these services they get provided free by
the government and then just think about
like how much further can we take these
so you know you know very easy with
private arbitration right now one of the
big limits on private arbitration is
that even if you sign a so-called
binding arbitration clause in fact if
the person that is a person doesn't like
how the binding arbitration turns out
they can go at a commando you or the
court yes they can take it works so for
example if you sign binding arbitration
saying you know in the event of any of
any employment to the dispute is going
on this will be handled by private
arbitration uh you know but that
contract in general is male like you
know why it might get a forced there's
no there's no confidence that would be
and again if you think about it well
yeah I mean like suppose that you can
sign is binding arbitration I could get
my brother-in-law to go and be the
arbitrator he always rose like favor you
could use this to get around the great
many government law if you can
understand why government doesn't want
to do this and yet clearly you could go
and allow a lot more room for private
arbitration and and actually it is
likely there is a mention and then spent
up demand for private arbitration that
is right now being stifled by regulation
right Emanuel and once you start
thinking about how could there be even
more do so like one like one obvious one
to be is if you go to government courts
then they say well actually if this is
if this is a private contract we do this
for quite you just have to have an
arbitration clause and it's not our
problem and only no like no like you so
if you want if you want to do dication
put an arbitration clause and all we do
there's dispute it shows the contract it
says this the arbitrator rubber-stamp
that's it yeah so maybe as an
intermediate yes you as the intermediate
step you would keep criminal stuff in
that event exactly exactly some a good
enough it's purely nightly basis exactly
yes i mean i think then when you just
start thinking about all the things that
you can hand over to the private so to
the private sector it is much larger
than what pietà what sort of than what
what it occurs first and then the
anarcho-capitalist idea is really once
we once we have privatized
all the things that at first it seemed
like you couldn't but we just keep going
further and further further on the end
you're left with almost nothing and then
the question is could you just get rid
of that last
it yeah so but a but a pause on the last
bit per second because you mentioned a
few different areas there but I think
the arbitration ones really interesting
I'm wondering when when you see cases of
arbitration now it must self select a
certain type of person to go ahead and
do that what what type of things are
being fought in arbitration you know to
me my new partner you have I guess you
really have a certain amount of money
you would not want to maybe know that
the person across the table from you is
in a similar situation or a similar
views that they'd be willing to accept
it as because you just said right at the
end they could probably figure out a way
to get this back into the court mean
it's fairly common actually just to add
it in a boilerplate into a contract
saying it will be arbitrated but the
people who really wanted I think are
people been burned by lawsuits from the
past people who've seen business deals
that's collapsed before their eyes
because the dispute came up and they
didn't work it out and then it took
years for them to go and resolve it and
by then the business was bankrupt so the
ovo or course if you've been sued by an
employee and you think you anything I
didn't think it was bogus that right a
thing like I ever wants that to happen
again so these these are like some
obvious cases of putting it in but you
know coercing like no employer is
thrilled about the idea of getting sued
yeah so no Union like if it were the
kind of thing you could really rely on
then I say I think it's very likely that
it would be totally standard to put in
private arbitration and just to avoid
like all like all the hassles that are
involved with hiring people right now
yeah again of course if you think these
laws are good then this is very
distressing to you on the other hand to
someone like me the fact that almost
everyone would probably happily sign
away the right to sue the employer shows
there's something very very bad about
the system we have like look it's the
kind of thing that is like the right to
sue your employer is the kind of right
the people will sign away for small
amount of money right which means that
it's probably not a very valuable right
to begin with it's the kind of things
that you're stuck with and it's written
many ways as a burden because then you
have to convince an employer I'm not
going to sue you I'm so uncool and well
in it also that the average person who
works for even a small company not just
a giant corporation we don't have
lawyers on retainer so I work for myself
which is a pretty beautiful thing but
I've worked at plenty of companies where
the day I you got hired I decide some
crazy book of all these are sure and of
course I didn't read all that stuff it's
like I'm not walking around with our
lawyer and most of our supplies were
just signing
I've been doing what they're saying
right which I would say is thank
goodness for that because if people were
actually people radically taking more
seriously and you Leary right now I
think your firms are taking advantage of
that my co2 gun to go and dilute it as
much as a llama Wow
I think I think though since I think the
regulations are bad in the first place
I'm all for people diluting the
regulations as much as possible yeah I
mean I was well you said there's no
saying thank God we don't get as much
governess we pay for all thank God we
don't sue people to anywhere near they
said that we legally could right because
it would be a hellish world yeah this
may sound like a very amateur question
but when people go into arbitration are
you bringing a lawyer with you or is it
just that the arbitrator is just looking
at what was sine and decide it like is
there a nettle argument that's taking
place right so I think it varies a lot
so sometimes you might bring a lawyer so
you know so we like it may actually
depend upon the rules of the arbitration
but you know I think you know a lot of
the ideas just to cut the expenses down
so a lot of times you don't have a
lawyer you just have an arbitrator there
who generally is well versed in the
industry that you're working in so he
actually knows what you're talking about
and then of course you know part of what
they're doing so there's something more
moderate called mediation where the
arbitrator doesn't have where the person
doesn't really get decide anything but
just tries to get the two people to talk
it's kind of like counseling and then
arbitration is stronger where he listens
to both sides and he tells you what's
going to be there always a set timeframe
on how long that lasts nearly well so
certainly not always in since this is
private there's this nail is like
there's a wide range there's a beautiful
rainbow of all possibilities you know
which are all done so you know there's
sometimes there's an arbitrator who just
says looking like we need tomorrow
that's it's rubber you know the story
here's here's what can happen and even
part of the beauty of that is once you
get the dispute resolved a lot of times
you can go back to working with each
other yeah we may not be too happy about
it but like there's no longer an ongoing
dispute and so it's settled and then you
can get back to business right and you
haven't paid an insane amount to load
right all right boy you're en are in
thrilled with these oh yeah yes probably
not either like so of course there's
Simon we're entrepreneurial not to see
well this is an opportunity for me to
branch out but yeah I think would be
very bad for lawyers and really
long-running and of course for
litigators particularly which is the
small minority of lawyers in the first
place but yeah you know some you know
like if you look for contract lawyer
this might be
awesome because then people then there'd
be a bunch of people who want to rewrite
all our contracts to go including by
putting binding arbitration that's
really an utterly binding right uh so
you mentioned earlier that even policing
could be pressurized but what would
happen so I can understand a place like
Beverly Hills people got a lot of money
we're going to privatize the Beverly
Hills Police Department Beverly Hills
Cop okay I saw the movie that was it was
about but I had to get that in there
somehow but what wasn't a place what
about the place were there with the
economics are terrible where people have
no money we're probably crime is the
highest whoo right right who's going to
put in money to how you gonna make a
profit off that yes so kina you realize
those places work where crime is
terrible or ones where the current
police already don't work very well so
we're just were stepping back and
realizing the current system is quite
crummy to begin with now like you know
who would pay for it otherwise so you
have the obvious place to start are
people actually are our landlords so
when you look like in a more suburban
area you're talking about homeowners
associations are some of the obvious
people pay for it but you know even now
in that area is very common for
landlords to pay for some kind of
security and if they know that it's
their job to do it I'll being in it will
show like a high crime area even someone
who is poor is going up values or life
values protection so you know sort of
like a like an economist joke as being
you know you see a lot of really
expensive sneakers and batteries down
but so why is this well like when it's a
priority people will come up with the
money in order to pay for things with a
really care about but you know the only
about policing is I mean I think it's
also better to think about it in a
broader category of just enforcement of
all kinds so like there's many kinds of
enforcement besides actual police so one
that's become very common with the
Internet is the all kinds of
reputational incentives so you know like
you know just like bad reviews things
like this you know these work far better
than like the FDA so you like imagine
you get a bad meal you go and call it
the FDA and complain about it or
something like actually like local meat
inspectors know like much more likely to
go and put in a bad yelp review and this
is the way that we are probably getting
most of our actual enforcement yeah like
you're like how what is protecting you
from food poisoning is it the government
General government's hardly doing
anything about it what's really breaking
from food poisoning is lolis word of
mouth which is now amplified because
it's know it now it is word of the
internet why
one complaint feeling my dad runs the
internet business like if one
disgruntled customer is terrible for you
and is really a much more effective
enforcement mechanism than anything the
government is doing about it
so as some of it that it's just the the
messaging has to be clearer because that
content seems very obvious to me in a
day of the internet right where you're
right people here now more about what a
yelp review of a restaurant says then
what either a written review in the LA
Times says or what you know what it says
that the restaurant what they're telling
you themselves so we that this is really
about messaging in a way more than
economics because I think people can get
there economically yeah and then again
also just thinking about ways that you
can get a contract between people that
you don't ordinarily think of as as a
connection relationship so right now we
all say like if you get an action with
someone you know a car accident you
don't have you don't have a contract
with a person you got an accident with
but if you both have insurance your
insurance company has relationship with
their insurance company so we of course
most auto accidents never go to trial
the insurance companies have a system
that they work out where they negotiate
with each other they've got standards so
again that's that's already going on and
then just think about any time you're in
a public place any time you're in a mall
also you like you right now of course
there's dispute there the police will
handle it but it is very easy to
visualize a world where when you go to
the mall there's actually a sign saying
like you know so when you enter this you
come under the jurisdiction of this
arbitration company and any dispute that
happened to the mall then is no longer
actually needs to be handled by the
police so yeah so your hands and then of
course people saying well I mean they're
just Lana cops you know they don't even
have a lot of them don't really have
guns of course if the taxpayers will pay
for someone to be shot at then few
companies are not going to pay are not
going to pay the extra mount to have
their employees right so the whole
system economics yeah sort of flip if we
yet we insist yeah so many oh simply I
mean the amazing thing about all of the
kinds of private up lvo a private law
that we see right now isn't that how
little it does but how much it does
given that the government provides these
services free of charge and people still
I will take money out of their own
pockets to go rat rather than go and get
the free stuff which yeah all right so
of course you it goes always the assess
is not for you have to be
is but another sense it is free namely
you can use it without any additional
charge so that's the sense in which the
cemetery I sometimes like you'll get
charged for false alarm although that's
pretty unusual but I think fire
department sometimes you call them for
no reason those that they'll give you a
bill so like why did you go and we slide
the services but normally that's not how
it works
you